so i have to ask i've seen these setups
where you guys are looking is your
computer monitor like this tiny little
window or do you get a real screen
um you're a small tv set kind of exactly
i like the size of a computer screen
yeah computer screen that shows you uh
generation
regeneration
and computer screen and is that ultraman
behind you or am i that old
it's because of the computer screen
you're on it's iron man um
it's okay it's okay i can't see it all
right
it's okay
robert downey he's he's not here he
couldn't see it i can't see i have bad
eyesight it's all right
before i get into asking you about the
movie i like throwing a curveball at the
beginning for both of you
if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
wow
we're gonna take this entire interview
time to listen i would have to take this
entire interview to choose between all
of uh
yeah i mean i'm gonna pick lou because
we're talking about lou right now and
lou i love to see people see me as this
mature woman in a role that you don't
usually see mature women in uh kicking
ass and and being a badass and surviving
and and going out for
you know justice and and
just being an incredible
woman going through it i don't know
i'm going with you right there
i'm with you i want them to see that too
you know we we never get to see this we
we rarely get to see a woman
this
fierce and mature and this you know
she's lived life lou you know and and
and yet
i mean she's you're standing right there
with the best of them i mean like that
can when you take that can of the neck
i mean it's just
that was stuff i have to say it was a
thrill to get to do because i've i've
always wanted to play in this genre i
just never thought i'd get an invitation
to and this script from jj abrams was
just
a gift to me and i i
was excited to to to portray this
character i loved how quiet she was how
serious how no you know no nonsense and
and just incredibly strong um and yet
obviously incredibly flawed uh which was
a wonderful journeys character she got
through to that side of lou that um
she doesn't often show she's a woman who
works by herself and and resents having
to work with with with um journey's
character um
just the the exploration of these two
women and their different paths in life
and and their judgment of each other and
ultimate respect for each other was a
great um story to tell to be honest with
you the reason i wanted to cover this
junket is because i'm a big fan of your
work allison and i want to see more
women kicking ass in these kinds of
roles so i'm happy to talk to you guys
about it um do you have a newfound
respect for like liam neeson and what he
did with the taken movies after doing
the physicality of this film yes i do i
really do i don't know how old liam was
when he started doing those taken films
but i you know uh at 61 it was a huge it
was incredible thing to to to to
challenge myself with and and the
physicality i was scared i was you know
i'm not gonna lie i did a lot of
training but i was also like please oh
god please don't let me i i just didn't
want to hurt myself and not be able to
do the get through the film and and um
and i i didn't i i thank the daniel
bernhard our you know the choreographer
who made it safe for us in all those
fights i knew exactly where he was and
where his arm was coming and what you
know that was all worked out so
specifically and um technically that it
made it almost impossible for for for us
to hurt ourselves and that was um great
and and we just felt protected on set by
the crew by our director anna we we
we felt it was a safe environment to
take chances physically for both of you
when i was watching the film i know how
films are made and the long hours and
when you're filming on location like you
did for this film it's it's a challenge
um so for both of you was it in the
script that it was going to be raining
all the time and then what day of the
shoot were you like okay this is this is
starting to get pretty challenging you
know that's you remember anna like maybe
two months before she actually put it in
the script where the rain was happening
so no i mean we knew it was a storm but
we didn't notice every single scene was
taking place in the storm and i also
remember saying to her shyly i said you
know um storms can happen during the day
you might save money like she's like oh
my god night shoots one of my least
favorite things to do as an actor i
thought okay
outdoors we're going to do an outdoors
night with rain and mud and bugs and
everything we just but it's a character
in the film like yeah it is the storm
the elements that these characters have
to work against is its own is its own
villain you know um and so as an actor
we just used it
um because the more discomfort that we
were in the more
we didn't have to actually
just like it just
showed on our faces the uh you know the
exhaustion and frustration and
it was it was it was incredible but
thank god i had journey to do it with me
because she's fearless and and didn't
once complain we both were like we sort
of relished it once we were in it we're
like we're wet and we're dirty and let's
do it let's go
i actually have an individual question
for both of you uh journey i early in
your career when you were a little kid
you worked on full house and i'm just
curious if you remember any of that uh
of working on that series
i know i was cast when i was like four
or four and a half god um so i can
remember i can remember
a little bit of it like the
feedback from the audience and that high
of getting that live reaction
of them laughing or whispering or you
know like that was my first experience
with that um but i don't really remember
a lot of it yeah god before i my career
didn't start till i was 38.
it was incredible
i wonder what i would have been like is
that i would have been too tall i was
too tall always to be cast in anything i
played my first role was that was uh the
undertaker's son
in the play oliver the musical was
amazing
that's amazing yeah allison i have an
individual question for you i am a big
fan of gareth edwards and greg frazier
and uh you are part of their new movie
and i'm just curious what can you tease
about it um what are you looking forward
to people seeing that was also an
interesting opportunity for me we shot
that in thailand uh that was an
extraordinary experience to go
i've never been to that part of the
world before and and that was it's an
extraordinary experience and um uh
working with john david washington who
was just a lovely assistant he's so
lovely i cannot tell you how much i fell
in love with that man and uh he comes
from great stock you know pauletta and
mark and chaka and uh and and just
gareth was a pleasure to work with it
was again a different i haven't been in
that world either i've sort of wanted to
play in different arenas and the the
action thriller and then uh the sci-fi
kind of i cannot wait to see what they
do with it because i saw all the previz
for you know what the actual uh location
looks like and then what they do with it
in post and the layers of coolness they
put on it it's going to be awesome
layers of coolness okay i'm excited
about that
um thank you so much for your time and
congrats on the movie i hope a ton of
people watch have a great day
you